it is commencement speech season have
you notice that giving their
commencement speeches right now and this
is a big deal do you hear about this one
a billionaire Robert F Smith gave the
commencement address to the graduating
class at Morehouse College and he
pledged to pay off all their student
loans yeah and guess what since his
Morehouse speech Smith has received
offers to speak at eight thousand other
University Wow he's the hottest ticket
right now is amazing yeah Oprah you sure
about this Oprah also gave a
commencement speech at the University of
Colorado and then she gave out to all
the graduates a copy of her book yeah
the book is called you should have gone
to Morehouse you know on a personal
level I wanted to talk about this I have
given two commencement speeches in my
day and at the time you know people like
them now I look like a dick
you can't give a commencement speech
anymore unless you promise to pay
everybody I'm getting calls now I gave a
speech at Dartmouth in 2010 I'm getting
calls on people like where's my money
I blame Ellen yes [ __ ] away to everybody
gotta be fair
whenever I bring up a problem that's
what Andy said yeah anytime I say yeah
you hear about those fires I blame al I
blame Ellen global warming Ellen Ellen
it is Ellen yeah